ce qui constitue un désastre social
majeur ne peut pas rester sans réponse
il me semble par conséquent que dans
toutes les instances accueillant des
mineurs il est indispensable de mettre
en place des dispositifs de recueil des
signalements d'écoute et d'enquête
internes pour les actes de maltraitance
or contrairement aux attentes qui
étaient les mienne lorsque j'ai rendu
publique le rapport sur les violences
sexuelles dans l'Église catholique absol
ent rien de sérieux n'a été engagé sur
le thème des violences sexuelles passées
dans l'ensemble des structures d'accueil
des mineurs qu'il s'agisse du sport mais
aussi de l'école de la protection de
l'enfance des mouvements de jeunesse de
l'éducation artistique des accueil
collectif de mineurs et même des autres
cultes alors que alors que les
conséquences de ces violences pour les
mineurs qui les ont subis ont été et
restent dans plus de la moitié des cas
graves ou très grave d'après notamment
euh les enquêtes que nous avons mené mon
sentiment est que l'inaction dans ce
domaine s doublé d'une forme
d'hypocrisie car à chaque révélation de
violence passée on assiste au même jeux
de rôle interprété à la perfection on
prend des mines éplorées les pouvoirs
public affiche leur indignation et leur
réprobation dans les termes les plus
sévères
leur compassion aussi pour les victimes
euh avec le plein appui de l'opinion il
désigne à la vinddicte quelques Bou
émissaire le plus souvent des
entraîneurs sportifs plus rarement tel
président de fédération qui a été
particulièrement défaillant mais ce jeu
de rôle entre guillemets évite de se
confronter au véritable problème et de
mettre à plat un passé bien plus sombre
que les quelques affaires révélées ici
ou là par les rares victimes en capacité
de parler publiquement de ce qui leur
est arrivé et de s'adresser à l'opinion
il permet aussi de se voiler la face sur
l'ampleur du mal et de ses conséquences
ainsi que sur les défaillantces
systémiques qui ont pu se produire dans
les différents milieux enfin il
n'apporte pas de réponse pertinente aux
problèmes et aux souffrances qu'un très
grand nombre de victimes de violence
sexuell vivent sur une longue période
selon moi par conséquent seul une
commission d'établissement des faits
dans chaque grande institution publique
ou privée d'accueil des mineurs serait à
la hauteur des problèmes posés